today on the matt wall show it is now
accepted as dogma that gender is a
social construct and men and women can
change their genders we're going to
explore the origins of this theory and
reveal the truth
about the degenerate quack who came up
with it you need to hear this so stick
around for it also five headlines
including the dastardly conspiracy that
caused nancy pelosi to break the
lockdown rules
by getting her hair done at a salon
she's the victim here okay in our daily
cancellation
speaking of victims we're gonna talk
about yet another rich celebrity who it
turns out
is being racially oppressed all of that
on the way before we get to any of it
i really want to tell you about our
friends charity mobile listen it can be
very difficult to find companies that
provide a great service but also
share your values you know as
conservatives this is an issue we
grapple with every day well let me tell
you
one company i support and you should
support too because they support the
causes we believe in and that is charity
mobile the pro-life phone company that's
what they're called for good reason
because with charity mobile it's pretty
simple five percent of your monthly plan
uh goes to the pro-life pro family
charity of your choice you get to choose
so
um not only is this a company with
values you
share but by simply paying your phone
bill you'll be able to
actively support the pro-life cause and
a lot of other great perks too
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
plus i love this
no contracts no termination fees no risk
with a 30-day guarantee if you have an
issue well they've got live customer
service on-call ready to help
and uh they're based in the usa as well
so to me this is the ultimate sort of
win-win
you get a great service you support a
great cause
and if we want to have companies out
there that are aligned with us
and what we believe then we've got to
support them when we find them which
isn't hard in this case because
charity mobile is simply a wonderful
service as simple as that uh call
charity mobile at 1-877-474-3662
chat with them online at
charitymobile.com that's
charitymobile.com
all right now it's taken as self-evident
these days that something called
gender exists and that it is distinct
from biological sex
and that the former and perhaps even the
latter they tell us now
is an artificial social construct but
these ideas were not always self-evident
in fact they weren't evident at all for
the entire history of the human race up
until about
a century ago thousands of generations
lived and died engaged in
art and science and philosophy and
everything else that comprises human
civilization
all while assuming that there were only
males and females and
rarely finding any need for other
categories
in the 20th century that all changed
considering the magnitude and suddenness
of this shift in our understanding of
human nature
we should probably take the time to
acquaint ourselves
with the people responsible for it and
when it comes to the concept
of gender and gender constructs there is
no better place to start than
a guy by the name of dr john money
he's a prominent was a prominent
psychologist and sexologist money was
one of the early pioneers of the gender
theories that are currently taught in
grade schools and universities um
among the first to take the word gender
out of the realm of grammar
which is where it originates and apply
it to people he coined the terms
gender role gender identity sexual
orientation all of that is from him
a professor at york university recently
published a book labeling john money
the man who invented gender so suffice
it to say
he was an extremely influential man and
anyone who propagates left-wing gender
theory today
is parodying at least some of the ideas
of john money
whether they know it or not and most of
the time they don't
but that fact that they're parroting his
ideas ought to trouble gender theory
proponents
because john money was among other
things a fraud a quack
and an abuser along with more
conventionally degenerate views his op
his advocacy of open marriages and group
sex for example
money was also as a not very critical
article in salon
puts it ambivalently supportive of
pedophilia
now drawing a distinction between what
he called sadistic pedophilia and
affectional pedophilia money held that a
relationship between a grown man and a
child
who really love each other should not be
considered disordered
speaking to a dutch a dutch publication
a pro-pedophilia publication money
explained quote
if i were to see the case of a boy aged
10 or 12 who who's intensely attracted
towards a man in his 20s or 30s
if the relationship is totally mutual
and the bonding is genuinely totally
mutual
then i would not call it pathological in
any way
his tolerance for child rape may help
explain
some of the events that transpire later
in the story
um jumping ahead now to 1965 and the
birth of twins bruce and brian ramer
the boys are born healthy except for a
condition called phimosis which affects
the foreskin it was decided
incorrectly it turns out that the best
way to treat this condition was
circumcision
but bruce's procedure went horribly
wrong and his penis was essentially
burned off of his body
after several months of grasping for
answers bruce's parents eventually
decided
to take him to johns hopkins in
baltimore to see the renowned dr john
money
the good doctor eager to prove the
legitimacy of his theory
that gender is a product of environment
and culture recommended that bruce
undergo sex reassignment surgery as a
baby
and before the boy turned two the deed
had been done his testicles were removed
some crude approximation of female
genitalia were formed
and money instructed the parents to
raise him as a girl from that day
forward
never tell him about his real identity
so
the rhymer parents tried to follow
money's advice but
they found that bruce was still bruce
even if they called him brenda and did
everything in their power to preserve
his fragile and false female identity
gender is a construct they were told why
should a boy raised as a girl still have
boyish tendencies yet
his boyishness came through in spite of
money's theories
the boys also attended regular therapy
sessions with money
for quote unquote therapy money
sometimes instructed the boys to disrobe
and inspect each other's genitals
sometimes they were made to simulate sex
acts on each other
money explained that this was meant to
be healthy sexual exploration
on at least one occasion nude
photographs of the boys were taken
ultimately money was convinced that you
know his project had been a smashing
success and
he bragged of his triumphs and many
published works
it was not a success the female identity
never took hold for bruce
because he wasn't a female he was
confused and miserable he was on the
verge of suicide at the age of 13.
finally his mother told him the truth
when bruce heard about this he chose
immediately to transition back to a boy
he took the name of david
he underwent another reassignment
surgery this time to try and reclaim his
true self
and he felt better for a time but
neither he nor his
twin brother lived happily ever after
their experience as
john money's lab rats had damaged them
irrevocably
david would go on to speak out against
money at first anonymously and then
publicly his brother did too
eventually david even got married but
all was not well
the first twin to kill himself was brian
in 2002 at the age of 36 the brother who
was used as a control group
in money's human experiment took a
lethal dose of antidepressants
two years later david drove to a grocery
store parking lot with a sawed-off
shotgun
shot himself in the head their deaths
will go down in history as suicides but
they were both murdered
by john money the father of modern
gender theory
i wish that this was all just a bit of
tragic and disturbing
historical trivia unfortunately though
john money's experiment
although it was a catastrophic failure
and his theories were dramatically
disconfirmed
he still achieved a victory on the
cultural battlefield
today ideas first proposed by a man
who thought child rape could be loving
and who performed a years-long
sexually abusive experiment on two
unwilling children
who later went on to kill themselves are
taken as gospel truth
and to question them is heresy the ramer
twins
were the first victims of money's
quackery but certainly not the last
in recent years there's been an
explosive rise in gender confusion among
children kids are
drugged and sometimes mutilated all in
accordance with
a theory that was proven false by the
guy who came up with it
money's modern disciples are just as
dishonest as money himself was though so
they push this sex reassignment stuff
and other barbarities
while claiming that the science proves
the efficacy of these measures
it doesn't they're lying the most
extensive and legitimate research done
on the subject has found
that transgenders still have sky-high
suicide rates
even decades after their surgeries
this is no surprise as david ramer's
parents discovered
you cannot reassign someone's
genetically and biologically hardwired
sex
you can dress them in different clothes
you can chop off body parts
but none of that can change their dna
you can alter the way a person looks
you cannot alter their biological nature
you cannot
change who they are john money's
experiment failed
the experiment that our society has been
carrying out on our children ever since
has also failed in its infancy gender
theory rot only confusion despair and
death
as it grows the results have not changed
they've only become more widespread
yet we continue down along this path
pretending not to notice the carnage i
think we need to start
noticing it let's get to five headlines
[Music]
you know as part of our daily wire
audience there are a number of ways to
get uh to take in the podcast you can
listen on apple podcast you can
go to spotify you can go to another
podcast app you can also watch our
podcast on youtube
facebook over at dailywire.com bottom
line our content is available in a lot
of places and there's no excuse not to
watch it i mean a personality personally
offends me
if you miss an episode if you don't
watch it hurts me deeply on a personal
level
and of course needless to say i am
oppressed um
every person who does not watch this
show is oppressing me so i'm being
oppressed by
you know billions of people and now
we're introducing a new upgraded
experience though daily wire is now on
apple tv and roku so members can enjoy
all of the visual elements on this
podcast on your big screen either live
or on demand find the daily wire app on
apple tv or roku
and download today go to dailywire.com
walsh
use code watch at checkout to get
15 percent off your memberships one
five percent off your membership deals
uh it's not it's not gonna it's not
gonna last long so you gotta go now
and uh you can watch apple tv or roku
all
you know just just more opportunities to
avoid uh oppressing me that's really the
headline here
okay now number one huge news here nancy
pelosi
is the victim of a setup a sting
operation a ruse
probably the russians are behind it we
can assume there was there was some kind
of
vast conspiracy afoot and the result of
the conspiracy is that nancy pelosi
got her hair done as we discussed
yesterday pelosi was caught
uh you know getting her hair done inside
a san francisco salon which is illegal
according to the lockdown you know the
lockdown that she
supports and has insisted upon
but she went in nobody else can but she
did she went and got a blowout a blowout
which apparently i'm told is the same
thing as a blow dry now why do we call
it a
blow out if it's just a blow dry why do
you need to go to a salon and pay
someone to use a hair dryer can't you do
it yourself these are all questions that
still are left unanswered and
also you know how is it that nancy
pelosi even still has hair at the age of
732.
another there's a lot of mysteries here
that are that are going on
um but she went in nonetheless and she
got her hair done now
the the assumption from a lot of people
no doubt many of them probably sexist
the assumption is that nancy pelosi did
something wrong
you know by defying lockdown orders uh
assuming that the laws didn't apply to
her and so on well she was asked about
this
during a press conference and she
explained
that no no no no she is the real victim
here
listen i take responsibility for
trusting
the word of a neighborhood salon that
i've been to over the years
many times and that when they said what
we're able to
accommodate people one person at a time
and that we can set up that time i
trusted that
as it turns out it was a setup so i take
responsibility
for falling for a setup and that's all
i'm going to say
on that i take responsibility for the
fact
that i am not responsible i take
responsibility
for being a tr a trusting kind
faultless angel who was exploited by
nefarious hair stylists who in their
free time i have learned just so you
know
do in fact drown kittens for fun and
cannibalize the elderly
i'm just lucky to escape with my life uh
and plus my hair looks gorgeous you have
to admit
that's just to summarize what she just
said there uh in other words she's you
know
all joking aside a horrible human being
i guess that's
that's how we can conclude this let's go
to number two
uh checking in with the gaff machine joe
biden here's his latest
what they're calling a quote unquote
gaff listen
ahead of your trip to kenosha wisconsin
tomorrow
last week your running mate senator
harris said that the officer who shot
jacob blake
based on what she has seen should be
charged do you agree with her and do you
also believe the same for the officers
who were involved in the death of briana
taylor
i think we should let the uh the
judicial system
work its way i do think there's a
minimum need to be charged the officers
and as well well as brianna taylor and
uh i might add by the way i think
what happened in uh in
portland where a one of the
trump guys riding along in vans and
citing
response is shooting rubber bullets i
guess or paintballs
apparently there was someone shot by
someone in the crowd with a bullet
killed i think that person should meet
the legal requirements that whatever
that calls for
we should be investigated and it should
follow through on what needs to be done
let the judicial system work let's make
sure
justice is done so the gaffe is supposed
to be that joe biden said brianna taylor
needs to be charged that's what he said
there
um but that's not really the point
the point is that joe biden is calling
for charges of officers
who according to all of the evidence we
have seen
acted appropriately to preserve the
lives of innocent people not just
themselves
but the other people around the kids in
the car that the knife-wielding
violent accused domestic abuser and
rapist was trying to
get into to evade arrest
they also act to protect them that's all
the evidence we have
but biden because he's not a good person
and he's a coward and a fraud and a weak
man
has no problem throwing the officers to
the wolves to score points politically
we think about this this guy is 78 years
old at the tail end of his life one way
or another okay 78
um and this is what he wants his final
chapter to be
appeasing a violent mob taking the side
of criminals against cops
throwing innocent men to the wolves all
in pursuit of a position of power
that he's barely conscious enough
even to appreciate
sad pathetic disgraceful but you know
all that aside
we did learn during the convention that
he likes vanilla ice cream with
sprinkles so
he's got that going for him at least
number three let's go to some uplifting
and happy news today from the daily wire
um a so-called antifa commander
who reportedly was armed
dropped to the ground and began crying
in the fetal position when law
enforcement officers stopped him at a
riot and placed him under arrest
this is something something a little
something to lift our spirits a little
bit this is nice
matthew banta 23 was arrested at a riot
late last week after he allegedly
ignored police commands and has been
charged with two counts of felony bail
jumping
and one count of obstructing an officer
the green bay press gazette reported
quote the charges
stem from a report about 9 pm saturday
that a whole bunch of white people with
sticks baseball bats and helmets
were headed towards the police who were
trying to break up what they deemed an
unlawful assembly in downtown green bay
following a protest saturday afternoon
uh so and you can see the commander
there
scary guy very tough looking this guy
apparently is
known for instigating violence all the
time he does that in between his shifts
at the t-mobile kiosk from the looks of
it
of course i'm joking there's no way he
has a job these losers don't have jobs
but it goes to show you know we call
antifa dangerous
and they are only because huge
crowds of people with weapons and and uh
and guns and bats
and no moral compass are always
dangerous right no matter how pitiful
and scrawny they are on an individual
level
but that doesn't say that these people
individually are
are tough you know you can give bats and
guns to a bunch of five-year-olds and
they would be
certainly a danger um
most of these antifa brats individually
are just
scared pitiful weaklings
and this is a game to them all the
cosplay conventions
are shut down because of kovid so this
is what they're doing instead
and that's why it has to be made real
you arrest them
put them in prison on real charges
real prison time and they could see this
is not just a game
okay number four the congealed
lump of semi-sentient oatmeal currently
presiding as
mayor of portland ted wheeler is moving
away from his 840
000 condo because it's been targeted so
often by rioters
remember though there's no violence no
problem in portland
everything's fine says wheeler as he
speeds away in his moving van in the
middle of the night
um the story of ted wheeler is really a
sad one
you know first of all as has already
discussed
at some point in his life a witch put a
curse on him and turned him into
a lump of oatmeal so that was his first
tough break and then he's elected mayor
and he does everything in his power
to legitimize the rioters provide cover
for them
aid and abet them in their terrorism
he's doing everything he can for them
everything you can hands the city over
to them
and says here here you go burn it to the
ground do what you want
and they still hate him they still hate
him even after all of that
yeah and i'm sure he's thinking himself
what can i what else can i do for you
people
and the answer is no it's never enough
ted
that's the answer maybe you've seen that
by now
number five and in our most important
story of the day uh david blaine
floated away in a balloon and was never
seen again actually i'm not sure
if that happened i didn't watch did
anybody watch
david blaine did his balloon stunt
yesterday i feel like nobody watches i
didn't see anything about it online
nobody was talking about it
the guy makes you know he goes out in
the middle of the desert with a balloon
and floats away just nobody cares or is
watching
somebody looks out their window and says
oh is that david blaine oh well
all right that gets back to what they
were doing um they live streamed the
youtube live stream david blaine
floating on balloons
and it was like a three hour live stream
i i mean did would anyone sit there for
three hours and watch a guy floating on
a balloon i don't know
now they called this stun ascension
that's what they called it
and at first when i heard that blaine
was going to do a stunt called
ascension i thought okay well
you know this is going to be a trick
where he uh
flies and and nobody can figure out how
he's doing it
you know something like that that's what
it's really what i thought it would be
and i thought well
that's pretty cool uh but then i learned
no he's just
floating with balloons how is that
why is that impressive humans have been
floating on balloons since like the
1700s the first
the first hot air balloon flight was in
the 1700s
this dude is 300 years late with this
trick
what is it going gonna invent the wheel
next
is he gonna ride down the street and a
bicycle
behold as he rides his huffy down the
street i don't know
i feel like this had to be the backup
stunt there must have been something
else they wanted to do that was really
cool and they couldn't do it and so at
the last minute they said
well you know you could float
with balloons and they just decided to
do that but anyway congrats to david
blaine for floating i hope that
he made it down safely all right let's
get to our daily
cancellation today for our daily
cancellation we're going to be canceling
disney
uh there are many reasons why you might
think we could cancel disney you could
cancel them for
pretty much every movie they've released
for the past 25 years or so because
they've all been bad but
today we're canceling them for a
different reason for being racist and
oppressive the details of disney's
persecution of minorities are
difficult to stomach but we must not
avert our gaze we must not look away
this is real
this is happening face it the daily wire
has the report
actor john boyega who played the
character finn in the disney
star wars saga denounced the film's
producers for allegedly sidelining all
the minority characters
and giving all the white characters more
nuanced storylines speaking to british
gq
boyega said that his advice for disney
going forward would be to
not market a quote black character who
they eventually sidelined
he said quote you get yourself involved
in projects and you're not necessarily
going to like everything
uh it's reported by the los angeles
times but quote
what i would say to disney is do not
bring out a black character market them
to be much more important than the
franchise than they are and then have
them
push to the sideline it's not good i'll
say it straight up
boyega charged that disney quote knew
what to do with
daisy ridley and adam driver's character
while not having a clue what to do with
oscar isaac
oscar isaac kelly tran or himself
uh he said quote like you guys knew what
to do with daisy ridley you knew what to
do with adam driver
uh you knew what to do with these other
people but when it came to kelly murray
tran
uh or when it came to john boyega you
knew f ethel so
what do you want me to say what what
they want you to say is i enjoyed being
a part of it it was a great experience
nah nah i'll take that deal when it's a
great experience
they gave all the nuance to adam driver
all the nuance to daisy ridley
let's be honest daisy knows this adam
knows this
everybody knows this i'm not exposing
anything
uh boyega opened up about the racism he
experienced from the star wars fan base
as well which was
at its hottest when the trailer for the
force awakens was first released
and he continued in his complaints
it makes you angry with a process like
that it makes you much more militant it
changes you
because you realize uh i got given this
opportunity but i'm in an industry that
wasn't even ready for me
nobody else in the cast had people
saying that they were going to boycott
the movie
uh because of uh because they were in it
okay there it is
sorry i you know stumbling a little bit
there i could barely finish reading it
through the tears
john boyega hollywood actor worth
millions
has suffered in ways that you simply
cannot fathom now you might listen to
his complaints and say first of all
the reason the black actors in the star
wars movie
didn't have nuanced roles is that nobody
in star wars had nuanced roles because
they were bad stupid films hardly
written and existed only as elaborate
toy commercials
you might also say that disney
prioritized wokeness over a storyline in
star wars
and in everything else they produce
these days you might point out that i
mean they're literally re-shooting their
old movies and recasting the white
characters as black
i mean you might say what more do you
want them to do
you might you might say also that john
boyega is just frankly not a very
interesting or good actor and he's lucky
to have been given any role at all
i mean the plumber who came to fix my
toilet last week could have probably
done a more compelling job in that role
than him
you might say so the fact that he's made
millions from a role that he brought
nothing to
should just cause him to be grateful the
way that i'm grateful that you all watch
this show despite the fact that i also
have no talent
you might also say finally that if
disney sidelined john boyega at all
it was mostly because they were
determined to turn star wars into a
girl power movie and that's why all of
the male protagonists were sidelined
even freaking luke skywalker was in the
move all three movies
he was in them for a total about 22
seconds because they were more focused
on you know being gender woke than
racial woke and so
if john boyega has any complaint that
should be the complaint
you might say if you are a racist
if you're not a racist you realize that
john boyega
now joins the ranks of michelle obama
lebron james
oprah winfrey as celebrities who are
rich admired and oppressed
and if you are a white person living in
a two-bedroom rancher
taking your 12-year-old ford escort to
your 37 000
a year job at the local walmart
distribution center you simply cannot
understand the oppression and a person
and persecution of celebrities who live
in homes as big as the warehouse you
work in
and who get paid more in a year than
you'll make in a lifetime you will never
know their struggle as much as you'd
like to because their struggles
certainly seem more glamorous and
profitable than your own
so disney is canceled for oppressing
the people that it pays millions of
dollars to
and you are canceled for daring to
assume
that a person is not oppressed just
because they're rich
famous powerful and free how dare you
how dare all of you prayers up for john
boyega in this
difficult time
moment of silence
that's it for the day thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton